esta misma semana y de hecho ese
documento ya fue depositado porque la
nubes que es la coalición de izquierda
que reagrupa a radicales de izquierda
socialistas ecologistas y comunistas ya
tenía listo ese documento mucho antes de
que Elizabeth pues ya explicará ante el
pleno de la asamblea nacional que iba a
recurrir precisamente a ese artículo el
49.3 que les permite pasar o adoptar
esta ley sin necesidad de el voto de la
asamblea nacional la primera ministra
que explicó que en vista de que se
habían pues después son más de mil
enmiendas que querían hacérsele a este
texto pues nunca se iba a lograr debatir
ni votar en los tiempos que se
necesitaba y que además ya se sabía que
la oposición Pues iba a votar en contra
de este texto además de esta moción de
censura que ya fue depositada por la
nupes también reagrupación nacional el
partido de ultraderecha de Marina López
en explicó que también espera depositar
este un documento similar el hecho es
que según la ley Pues tienen 24 horas
para hacerlo cualquiera de los de los
partidos de la asamblea nacional para
hacer esto y ahora que esperar al menos
unas 48 horas antes de que se dé el voto
para que una moción de censura sea
adoptado pues tiene que hacerlo por la
mayoría absoluta de la asamblea nacional
y de ser así pues simplemente sería el
final del gobierno de la primera
ministra de Francia Elizabeth